good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight one of the weirdest
features of modern life has got to be
how we've all been trained to ignore the
things that really matter
you might have wonders to pick one among
so many examples why hundreds of
thousands of your fellow americans seem
to be living in squalor on the sidewalk
how'd that happen
these are the so-called homeless drugs
have destroyed their lives so where'd
those drugs come from exactly and why is
no one asking
and speaking of chemicals men in america
seem very different from what they used
to be anyone over 40 knows this the
changes are dramatic you can't help but
notice
could those changes have something to do
with the unprecedented drop in
testosterone levels that scientists have
measured repeatedly
and by the way if that's happening why
is it happening and so on there's so
many questions like this but we really
talk about any of them instead we're
told repeatedly to avert our gaze from
the obvious and turn instead to cnn's
latest fixation whether it's a chinese
flu virus or george floyd or some
forgettable border dispute in eastern
ukraine
these are the issues they tell us we
must care about but they're wrong these
are not the most important issues
they're just news stories the only
remarkable thing about them is our
willingness to believe they're more
important than say americans living
outdoors on the sidewalk or whether or
not our own children get married
there's something a little scary about
watching this happen it's like an entire
population transfixed by issues that
ultimately don't really matter
how's that going to work out well over
time probably not very well
reality always reasserts itself twitter
can ban all the thought criminals it
wants but in the end twitter is not in
charge of the future nature is in charge
of the future if you want your country
to continue you have to answer nature's
imperatives which are the basics do you
have enough water do you have a reliable
food supply can you defend yourself from
invaders what are you using for energy
how are you producing things and keeping
warm
those are the essential questions that
any civilization must ask those and one
other
how many people do you want living in
your country
the size of your population matters very
much the size determines a nation's
character it often determines its fate
yet we don't talk much about the size of
our population we probably should the
united states is growing faster than
most americans understand if you were
born in 1969 as some of us were you
arrived in a country with a little over
200 million people in it there are now
334 million people in it
that's an awful lot of new people in an
awfully short time how many people is
that exactly well it's nearly twice the
population of the entire western united
states that's 13 states including
california that is massive and
incredibly rapid demographic growth and
it's accelerating immigration is now at
the highest level ever recorded in
american history so is the number of
foreign-born already living here
over just the last year roughly two
million people from the third world came
across our borders illegally all of them
arrived with the blessing of the white
house
it makes you wonder what sort of economy
joe biden imagines we're going to have
going forward domestic manufacturing is
in steep decline automation is replacing
many of the low-skilled jobs that still
remain
so what are these millions of new people
going to be doing for work 20 years from
now they can't all be nancy pelosi's
housekeepers they can't all bus tables
at the french laundry in napa
and not all of them will thank god
in spite of the democratic party's best
efforts to import a permanent surf class
to serve its donors some of these
immigrants will rise higher than nancy
pelosi expects they will some will fight
their way to the top of our society with
the usual combination of inborn talent
and grit
and honestly bless them for that no one
invited them here we didn't want them to
come but we will be sincerely glad when
they succeed
and yet
a country is more than the success of a
handful of people inspiring as that
always is to watch sheer numbers matter
too
even if every single person who snuck
across our southern border this year
goes on to win the nobel prize in
chemistry it would still be worth
worrying about the effects that mass
immigration have on our total population
numbers
so the question is how many people is
too many
in washington you will never hear that
question
more bodies in a country mean more power
for the people who run it big nations
need big governments politicians always
want more people to rule so the
incentive for unrestrained population
growth is baked right into the system
that's bad news for the rest of us
first and most obviously big governments
don't treat their citizens very well yes
that's a reagan era talking point it's
also true
the larger a bureaucracy becomes the
more impersonal it gets past a certain
size organizations of any kind lose
their regard for people as they get
bigger they get blunter more soulless
and cruel the people in charge no longer
care what you think they don't have to
worry about how their policies will
affect you or your family
and that's the inevitable product of
population growth if you had five
children you would bathe them all in
love and attention if you had five
thousand children you wouldn't know
their names
so in case you're wondering why our
leaders no longer seem especially
interested in your health or happiness
or prosperity that's the reason they
don't have to be interested
our population's too big why should your
opinion matter you're one of many
previous generations of americans didn't
live in a country like this and they
would be stunned by the attitudes that
are so common now attitudes we take for
granted
arresting people for walking through the
u.s capitol building how is that a crime
19th century americans would wonder
for most of our history americans
believed they owned the capital they
thought it was theirs because they
assumed this was their country
political leaders told them that it was
after the 1904 presidential election
teddy roosevelt greeted voters in person
on the lawn of the white house
it was his home he lived there but it
belonged to them
attitudes like that are long gone
they're the victim of population growth
the athenians dement invented democratic
government but at its peak athens only
had about eight thousand voters
so past a certain scale democracy can't
function very well the concept of the
citizen becomes too abstract
you see it in the way our leaders talk
politicians barely mention individuals
anymore instead they yammer on about
voting blocks which are now called
communities the immigrant community the
trans community the latino community the
black community
you hear these terms constantly but they
are nonsensical they don't mean anything
for example there are about 47 million
black people in the united states that's
a community no it's not by definition 47
million people cannot be a community no
matter what color the people within it
are how could it be a community they
don't even know each other what you're
looking at is not a community but 47
million individuals each created by god
as unique each with opinions and
interests and preference and goals that
aren't quite the same as anybody else's
in other words they're human beings
people who run big countries tend to
forget that when you're in charge of
hundreds of millions of people you
cannot help but to dehumanize them not
that our leaders have ever had a problem
with dehumanizing people in fact they're
strongly for it
a year and a half ago some idiot kid
from harvard wrote a book demanding that
the united states open its borders to an
additional 700 million new immigrants
from around the world
if we did that he argued in the book
we'd have a population of a billion
people and that might raise our gdp wall
street would be thrilled also of course
you'd be more diverse with more
interesting restaurants want sierra
leone and goat barbecue delivered to
your pot at 3am with a billion people
living here you could get that done
as noted the kid's a [ __ ] but in
washington here's the interesting part
no one laughed at him
quite a few ostensibly smart people
agreed with his thesis including some
prominent republicans who turned out to
be as dumb and reckless as he is
apparently none of them has ever spent
time in a crowded country
anyone who has knows how deranged it is
to want a billion people here in the
united states
mass population growth makes life worse
for pretty much everybody that's the
main problem with crowded countries
they're hard to live in they're loud and
dirty and chaotic there is no privacy
there is no open space there are never
enough resources to go around so the
culture tends to become hyper
competitive and clannish
crowding is bad for people it's
anti-human
in a famous series of experiments in the
late 1940s a researcher called john
calhoun forced a group of norway rats to
live in highly overcrowded pens and
almost immediately the rats changed they
became aggressive then they became
psychotic ultimately they died
people aren't so different from that
they need room that's why our ancestors
came to america in the first place
because there was room here
you know who still understands this rich
people understand this ask anyone who's
been around the world and knows what the
options are ask if you left the united
states where would you move
and no one's going to tell you lagos or
mexico city or even singapore if they're
being honest they'll tell you new
zealand or alpine switzerland
those are low density places they don't
have a lot of other people in them why
do billionaires buy huge boats same
reason the ocean isn't crowded there's
no one else there
uncrowded is good
yellowstone is beautiful because it's
empty
you don't have to be rich to understand
this it's all pretty obvious really only
in a moment like this one when the
people with the megaphone speak
exclusively in lies would we need to be
reminded of it
bigger is not always better in fact most
of the time it is worse
have you driven around your country
recently
you may have noticed there are fewer and
fewer beautiful things in america you're
not imagining that it's real dollar
stores are everywhere
the question is why is this happening
well the people in charge have no taste
that's part of it they acquire but they
can't discern
for some reason we put private equity
firms in charge of the nation's
aesthetics accountants are doing our
exterior design
that's a terrible idea obviously but
it's not the core problem the core
problem is that bigness is inherently
ugly there's never been a beautiful
skyscraper every single one of them is
an atrocity the fact that people still
pretend otherwise tell you you how
conditioned we have become to disregard
our own nature and our own natural
longings would you rather wake up in a
30 million condo on the top floor of an
office tower
or in a log cabin in a pine forest wood
stove glowing as the snow falls
that's rhetorical question obviously no
sane person would choose the condo and
yet we're told the condo is better
that's why it costs more because
the building is bigger
but how exactly is its scale in
advantage how is that appealing what's
not in fact its scale is the problem
massive size is a threat no matter what
it is always
in our bones we understand this
anything huge is inherently terrifying
to us children run from big things
if there's an upside to the last two
years of the coveted insanity and there
may be it's that many americans seem to
be remembering what they long for look
where they're moving almost always it's
to some place smaller la to austin new
york to burlington seattle de boise
chicago to naples so it's the reverse of
any other internal migration we've ever
seen americans are moving from the
cities to the farms or at least to the
outer suburbs
they want more nature more human contact
more trees more quiet
and it's hard to believe they'll ever
stop wanting these things
because they're natural they're the
things we all want
at some point down the road you can
imagine young people setting out for the
all but abandoned interior of our
continent
some of them may figure out that a
depopulation depopulated finnish settler
town on the banks of lake superior may
be a better place to live and raise
children than some sterile commuter
parking lot 20 miles from a crumbling
metroplex
they could figure that out people aren't
that stupid
they've just been misled
economic forces are going to drive this
by the way as they always do for decades
our leaders
have ignored the essentials our food our
energy our water in favor of boutique
nonsense that improves nobody's life
pregnant flight suits ladies and
gentlemen
these people are ridiculous and we're
about to see the results of their
long-standing negligence energy prices
for example probably aren't going down
how high are they going to go nobody
knows but at some point it will become
very obvious that it makes more sense to
buy your staples maybe nearby more sense
than it does to order them online from a
warehouse across the continent
so the
rising cost of transportation is likely
to be permanent the world we live in in
other words cannot last
and that's not necessarily a tragedy
there's nothing wrong with setting down
roots somewhere that's smaller it's not
a bad thing to know the man at the
grocery store or the ladies at the post
office is pretty nice actually it might
even be an improvement over midtown
manhattan believe it or not
healthy societies are not at all like
the one we are living in now they're not
impersonal they don't exist to maintain
empires they exist to serve the human
beings who live within them they elevate
their citizens they don't degrade them
now obviously that's the opposite of the
system we currently have
the good news is the system we currently
have cannot last it's too perverse it's
too connect disconnected from the
natural world so it will end
and as it does end as we think about how
we want to live going forward it's worth
remembering that other people in the end
are all that matters
your relationships are the sum of your
life
those relationships start with your
family they move outward in concentric
circles they include your friends your
neighbors and the people you work beside
this is your actual community the human
beings you know personally the ones you
love the ones you take responsibility
for and that can never be a very big
group hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else